whenever you ask people who the
strongest straw hats are they will
without any doubt tell you Luffy and
Zoro but Sanji well there's some really
intense debates going on about how
strong he actually is so to end the
Sanji ha once and for all let's give him
the perfect devil fruit for him to take
him into the top tier of fighters in the
story which just leaves us with one very
important question which devil fruit is
the best one for Sanji and let's start
with one of the coolest devil fruits in
the story which is the ice fruit and to
really explain why these chili powers
are simply one of the best devil fruit
fits for Sanji we have to break down
exactly what makes our curly eyebrow
Chef so so special for example that one
of sanji's main passions is of course
cooking so his perfect devil fruit would
definitely need to somehow at least
contribute to his cooking skills as well
I think and the ice devil fruit would
absolutely help Sanji as a chef because
what cook doesn't need a way to keep
their food refrigerated he's basically
his own freezer and on top of that being
able to actually control temperatures
has a ton of applications as a chef as
you can make special dishes by being
able to instantly freeze food but what
of course even more special here is that
it is one of the only devil fruits that
can literally create water so that the
straw heads would simply never run out
of water with Sanji being around them
and so all around pretty strong in just
the cooking category but on top of that
we of course also have to consider how
this devil fruit would improve his No
Hands fighting style as well of course
the Sanji that we know posano already
has a super strong durable body and
quite Incredible strength but the ice
fruit would give him huge huge boosts in
defense and attack power very early in
the story which could make him nearly
Unstoppable in basically every one of
his main fights plus the ice fruit wood
in insanely enhance sanji's kicking
based combat as well he could just make
his leg super cold which could freeze
anyone he touches he could also add icy
blades to his kicks or even combine his
natural fir Powers with these new ice
abilities to kind of be the ultimate hot
and cold fighter plus of course he could
shoot out ice projectiles and even
freeze water itself so that the straw
heads never have to worry about drowning
ever again plus I'm pretty sure that he
could just tag team with nami to create
some truly insane weather based attacks
by creating cold air for Nami to
manipulate as well and so right out of
the gate you might be thinking that this
already must be the perfect fruit for
Sanji but we actually have many many
more fruits that might be even way
better fits for the straw hat Chef
including the one that he dreamed about
as a child and that's of course the Suki
suomi right here otherwise known as the
invisibility fruit and for many people
this is the first Power that they
probably think of when it comes to
giving Sanji a devil fruit and that's
because during the Thriller bark Arc we
learned from Sanji himself that he
always wanted to eat this fruit ever
since he was a child because of rather
perverted reasons and honestly if that
was all that Sanji used his fruit for
then he probably wouldn't live a very
long life with the straw hats because
I'm pretty sure that Nami would just
straight up kill him for peeping on her
in the shower but let's assume that he
could actually control himself when it
came to the ladies or be really at
hiding himself and seriously evaluate
this fruit as a fighting option for
Sanji as well because first off the
invisibility powers for obvious reasons
are incredibly useful in combat as he
can hide from most opponents in fact he
already got a literal invisibility power
up in wano with his family's technology
but instead he actually chose to destroy
his invisible suit in the end not that
it really matter though because at this
point Sanji moves so so fast that he is
basically already invisible and so that
power really would again just be a huge
buff for early story Sanji besides that
the fruit wouldn't really be all that
useful for Sanji outside of that since
it doesn't make him technically any
stronger it also doesn't help with his
cooking much except for maybe keeping
his dishes a surprise I guess so overall
I don't really think that this fruit is
all that great as a serious option for
Sanji but one that we had to discuss
nonetheless but this next fruit here
might actually be the best fruit for
Chef Sanji at least because we all know
that a knife is a chef's best friend so
of course any chef would simply love to
get the dice fruit which in case you
forgot allows its user to turn any part
of their body into a blade which
honestly is just absolutely perfect for
Sanji since he is constantly slicing and
dicing fruit in the kitchen but beyond
just simple knives he could also turn
himself into so many different kinds of
blades that are just useful in the
kitchen such as a spinning blade to use
as a blender or a rough blade to act as
a grater so clearly this fruit has truly
endless uses in the kitchen beyond that
though it is also pretty perfect with
sanji's fighting style because he can
just turn his entire leg into a sword
and use that to attack his enemies which
honestly would make him even more deadly
than he already is in particular this
fruit would have probably helped Sanji a
ton during his brief clash with
doflamingo because if we assume that at
this point Sanji is pretty good with
using his double fruit and has decent
levels of hockey as well then there is
literally no better power to fight do
Flamingo strings than a bunch of blades
so who knows there might not have even
been the entirety of the dress Rosa Arc
if Sanji just had had this devil fruit
however I do have to admit that it would
be a little bit weird to see Sanji using
blades since that has always been of
course zoro's thing plus you can just
imagine Sanji doing this to his captain
with the blade legs
yikes that would be a bye-bye to Luffy
although on the other hand I guess you
could say that Sanji and Zoro could take
their rivalry to the absolutely Next
Level by dueling with their blades but
if we're being honest here though Sanji
would need a ton of practice to actually
learn how to use this fruit properly
which we actually wouldn't need if he
ate this next devil fruit and before you
laugh right here just know that this is
my personal favorite fruit for Sanji
which is the big horn sheep devil fruits
that we created right here and while
this fruit yes is currently not actually
a thing in the story the inspiration for
this power actually comes from chapter
651 with its color spread here where we
see all of the straw hats as animals and
honestly I just think that this is so
cool and weirdly awesome to look at but
if you think about it being a born sheep
could actually be a huge fighting boost
for Sanji because in case you didn't
know these animals are truly insane
they're known for their incredible
jumping and balance which basically
allows them to climb entire Cliffs that
seem to be completely Smooth by jumping
up to 20 ft high and then landing on the
tiniest Ledges which of course does mean
that for Sanji who attacks mostly with
jumps and kicks adding this natural
boost to his leg power would make him
even more powerful than he already is
now of course this is also a Zone devil
fruit in general so Sanji would also get
quite a few natural boosts in all of his
physical stats like strength speed
endurance and Recovery Plus on top of
that he gets the hybrid and full Zone
forms as well which surprisingly might
change his fighting style quite a bit as
well because I mean one of his biggest
rules is to never fight using his hands
but if he has these massive horns on his
heads or hoofs as hands he would
basically have to use them right however
the one downside to this fruit is that
it doesn't really have any real
applications for Sanji as a cook so
while it would be awesome and really fun
to see probably isn't the best fruit for
Sanji as a cook which you could say is
the exact opposite case of this next
fruit here which is the cook cook fruit
that we were introduced to during the
hul kick island arc now in case you
don't remember because this was kind of
a minor character this fruit basically
allows you to turn anything into fruit
for example this guy who actually ate
this fruit turned this log of wood into
a slice of meat and he later turned big
mom's entire ire Castle into a gigantic
sponge cake and so of course we do have
to discuss this fruit here because it
does seem like an absolute perfect fit
for a chef like Sanji right well I'm
here to tell you no because this fruit
would just destroy the Sanji that we
know and love for one this is basically
like a cheat Cod for a chef since you
literally don't even need to cook to
make any food and so for someone like
Sanji who takes a ton of pride in his
cooking he would would likely feel like
he'd rather cook something incredible on
his own rather than just instantly
making food with his devil fruit or
alternatively if he actually ate his
fruit as a kid and then relied on it for
his cooking he might have actually never
gotten to be the incredible Chef that he
is today plus we aren't even entirely
sure how good the food made by this
fruit tastes I mean big mom certainly
didn't like the taste of the cake made
from the fruit so it's possible that the
food doesn't taste good at all although
to be fair it's very possible that the
quality of the food produced by this
fruit probably also depends on the skill
of the user and the situation so food
made in an emergency probably wouldn't
be as good as something made with time
and preparation and to be completely
fair this is literally the perfect fruit
to have on a ship if you start running
out of food like what happened to the
crew on the way to hul Kake Islands
however of course I have very serious
doubts about Sanji actually using the
cook fruit in combat because the only
way I could see sanjing using it in a
fight is to turn up other people's
weapons or maybe even other people into
food like for example he was fighting a
swordsman Sanji could probably turn his
opponent's sword into I don't know a
banana or something which would
seriously weaken his opponent but if
we're being honest it is a kind of weak
combat ability compared to the other
powers that we've already mentioned and
the insane ones coming up next because
even though the cook fruit was not a
great fit for Sanji there actually is a
food-based devil fruit that is a way
better fit for him and that is the
arguably strongest food fruit that we
know about so far which is katak Curry's
Mochi devil fruit which would be
absolutely perfect if we had to pick a
food-based devil fruit for Sanji that's
because this so-called special paramia
devil fruit has nearly all the benefits
of a loia fruit with the added benefit
being that the substance Sanji could
turn into is also edible and so it's
both great for combat and in the kitchen
let's break it down of course for one
with Mochi Sanji could make an endless
supply of Mochi based treats So in
theory the crew would never go hungry
which is a major bonus for this fruit
already however since Sanji can turn his
entire body into Mochi as well and
produce the sticky sweet substance too
he gets a major boost in all of his
combat moves as well for example as we
saw when big mom's strongest son
katakuri used this devil fruit Sanji
would be able to create Mochi
projectiles and take out opponents from
far away he could also enhance his kick
with Mochi by making his legs extra
strong and even extending their reach so
yeah this is pretty much an optimal
fruit if we're combining his role as a
chef and a fighter however even the
multif fruit simply cannot compare of
course to the incredible powers of the
pika pika Nomi also better known as the
light fruit and I mean this this fruit
regularly ranks near the top strongest
devil fruits on any list and for very
good reasons for one since this fruit is
a loia Sanji would get the very obvious
benefits of being able to turn his
entire body into light and shoot out
light lasers as well and really there's
almost no better fruit to enhance
sanji's fighting style than by making
him even faster than he already is
because I mean we've already seen just
how devastatingly fast Sanji was during
the wano arc but this devil fruit would
take him to a whole different level and
on top of just making him faster Sanji
would also be able to shoot laser light
beams although as with many of these
devil fruits it's kind of questionable
if Sanji would ever use a longrange
attack like this I mean we've actually
seen him pull out a gun twice in the
story but he's never fired a single
bullet so would he shoot out light
bullets with his devil fruit it's kind
of debatable for sure but as long as
he's not using his hands I do feel like
Sanji could do it and so yeah without
any doubt this fruit no matter who eats
it honestly would be a true monster for
combat but how about using it in the
kitchen well in order to effectively use
light for cooking Sanji would need
incredible and I mean incredible precise
control over these Powers but if he
could actually manage to master that
fruit he could use his light to heat up
and actually cook food since light heats
up objects as it passes through them so
much like the ice devil fruit this could
lead to some fancy new cooking
techniques that I'm pretty sure Sanji
would absolutely love to test out but
there's of course one thing that the
light fruit wouldn't do for Sanji and
that is get rid of his number number one
weakness of course I'm talking about the
fact that Sanji still refuses to fight
women which has cost him pretty badly on
more than just one occasion in the story
however to counter this exact weakness
there are actually two fruits that would
help Sanji never have to fight a woman
ever again and I'm of course talking
about this person's hormone fruit which
can inject someone with enough hormones
to make them switch genders and I mean I
guess that would be one option and the
other one involves a brief manga spoiler
here but we all also have this guy's
sickick fruit which can actually infect
people with a gender swapping disease
and technically both of these would
allow Sanji to change women into men so
that he would have no problem fighting
them which basically takes away his
biggest weakness as a fighter right now
although knowing Sanji he would probably
never want to change a woman into a man
so maybe these aren't too great for him
after all and so even with all of these
incredible devil fruits that we've
picked so far I still wonder if we
couldn't just craft the per perfect
fruit for Sanji that would put him on
the same levels as even Luffy or Zoro
and since these two are both essentially
Gods I mean Luffy is literally the Sun
God and Zoro has his Ashura demon powers
as well I did figure why not try and
give Sanji some sort of mythical god
Powers as well and so after doing some
research I actually found out that there
is a Japanese deity called ukim Moi who
is the god of food which of course just
sounds absolutely perfect for Sanji
because ukim Moi is said to be able to
create any kind of food or even help
crops to grow better now that is
obviously a major Plus in the chef
category since Sanji could produce any
ingredient that he could imagine to
create some truly out of this world
recipes like seriously Sanji would be in
heaven especially since his dream of
finding the all blue specifically
mentions cooking with some special fish
that you can't find anywhere else in the
world so yeah this route would be
perfect for Chef Sanji but fighting is a
whole another matter though because at
first it doesn't seem like this fruit
would have like any real effect on his
fighting style and you might actually
think that with his endless supply of
ingredients Sanji could just whip up
some deadly dishes to poison his
opponents but I truly don't think that
Sanji would ever want to make food that
would hurt someone and so let's actually
flipped us around and imagine that with
enough practice Sanji could make food
that actually boosts his own strength
endurance recovery or some other
characteristic that he chooses for
example I'm just just imagining him
getting ready to fight by taking a bite
of some sort of special strength
boosting meal or something like that
which would be perfect to share
obviously also with other people like
the other straw hats although I don't
really know if he would share with Zoro
here but this fruit might even be enough
to settle their age old rivalry once and
for all however of course this is only
considering Zoro at his current actual
strength in the story but it would be a
completely different story if Zoro had
his own devil fruit to actually compete
with Sanji and if you want to see which
devil fruit is the perfect one for our
green Hur swordsman here you can watch
that video right here as well Shanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one